- Good morning Believe Nation,
my name is Evan Carmichael,
my one word is believe.
And I believe that
entrepreneurs will solve all of
the world's major problems.
So to help you on your
journey, today's message is:
take action.
Over to you Mel Robbins.
(rooster crows)
- ♫ I wake up every morning
♫ Entspresso keep me going
♫ I wake up every morning
- One night, Chris had gone to bed.
I had been struggling,
struggling, struggling.
We still had all the same problems.
I, we still had a lien on the house,
still facing bankruptcy,
still fighting like crazy,
I was still unemployed.
He still, they still
hadn't figured out, like,
the solution yet for the business.
And I was about to turn off
the TV, and there on the TV
there was this rocket
launching, and I thought,
Oh my gosh, that is it!
I am going to launch myself
out of bed like a rocket ship,
like NASA, right here, had
launched me out of that bed.
And I am going to move so
fast that I don't think.
- Mm.
- I'm going to beat my brain.
Now here is a really interesting point.
I talk a lot about your
instincts and inner wisdom,
and we can get into
this a little bit later,
but a lot of us talk about
the fact that you have
a gut feeling.
But what all this research
that I've done for the book,
and all the speaking that
I do, what I've discovered
that's fascinating is
actually, when you set goals,
when you have an intention on something
that you want to change about your life,
your brain helps you.
What it does is it opens up a checklist
and then your brain goes to
work trying to remind you
- Yeah.
- of that intention that you set.
And it's really important
to develop the skill.
And I say that word
purposefully, the skill
of knowing how to hear that inner wisdom
and that intention kicking in.
And leaning into it quickly.
- Mmm.
- So for me, my brain saying,
that's it, right there.
Move as fast as a rocket, Mel.
I wanted to change my life,
and I think most people
that are miserable, or
that are really, like,
dying to be great,
- Mmm.
- and dying to have
more, we want to change,
we want to live a better
life, we want to create more
for our families, we want to be happier.
The desire is there.
Again, it's about how do you
go from knowledge to action?
So the first thing in this
story that's important
is realizing that the answer
was in me, and my mind
was telling me, pay attention.
It could have also been the bourbon.
(laughs)
I mean I had a couple
Manhattans that night, but.
Anyway, the next morning,
the alarm goes off
and I pretended NASA was there.
It's the stupidest story.
I literally went five,
four, three, two, one.
I counted out loud, and then I stood up.
And I'll never forget
standing there in my bedroom.
It was dark, it was cold,
it was winter in Boston.
- Mm-hmm.
- And for the first time in three months,
I had beaten my habit of
hitting the snooze button.
I couldn't believe it, and
I thought, wait a minute.
Counting backwards, that
is the dumbest thing
I've ever heard of in my entire life.
Well the next morning I used
it again, and it worked.
The next morning I used
And then I started to notice
something really interesting.
There were moments all
day long, all day long,
just like that five second moment in bed,
where I knew, knowledge, what I should do.
And if I didn't move within five seconds,
my brain would step in
and talk me out of it.
- Mm.
- Every human being has
a five second window.
Might even be shorter for you.
You have about a five
second window in which
you can move from idea to
action before your brain
kicks into full gear and
sabotages any change in behavior.
Cause remember, your brain
is wired to stop you from
doing things that are
uncomfortable, or uncertain,
or scary.
It's your job to learn how
to move from those ideas
that could change everything,
into acting on them.
- Taking action is a cure-all.
Taking action solves all the problems that
you're going through.
Whatever problem you have, whatever thing
is in front of you,
whatever obstacle is there
that seems usurmountable,
it's not going to get fixed
by just sitting and
complaining and wallowing,
and feeling sorry for yourself.
It happens from taking action.
As soon as you can move from that place
of being unhappy and desperate,
and sorry for yourself
to how do I solve this?
Who do I need to contact to help me?
How can I use the resources
I have to fix this?
As soon as you start moving to that land,
that's when you start to make progress.
Taking action is the cure-all.
This is what happens so
many times to entrepreneurs,
not even just with problems,
but with ideas in general.
How often do you get an idea for something
that you want to do, and
then you say, tomorrow
I'm going to do it?
And then tomorrow comes, you don't do it.
How many times?
That happens, that happens
over and over and over and over
and again. It's a human condition.
It's not just entrepreneurs.
We have these things, these
ambitions, these drives
that we set for ourselves
and then we don't
follow through on.
The best way to start
on that idea you have
is to take action.
Do something immediately.
As soon as you set a goal, I
want to start a YouTube channel.
Great.
What are you going to
do on You Tube channel?
I want to interview people.
Amazing.
Today, set up your YouTube
channel and send out
ten emails to people to
ask them for interviews.
People that you know, people
who you think will say yes.
When you commit to somebody
else, you're much more
likely to follow through.
And what happens is perfection
becomes the enemy of action.
You want to make it perfect,
and because you make it perfect
it gets more and more and
more and more complex,
and complexion is the enemy of execution.
Because you build it up
to be this big thing,
this big scary thing
that has to be perfect.
You don't do anything.
Before I set up my YouTube
channel I need to have
the perfect channel
art, and I need to have
the right thumbnails, and I
need to know what my script
is going to be, and I need
to know my intro and opener,
and I need the gear.
All of these things that
you need to have to make
a perfect video.
And because it becomes this big thing,
you don't do anything about it.
And then the next day you
wake up, and it's gone.
Poof.
As soon as you set a goal for yourself,
I want to go and do this,
the best next thing
you can do is take some
form of immediate action and ideally,
commit to somebody else.
Whether it's a friend, whether
it's a potential customer,
whether you're sending emails
out, whether it's your family,
whether it's a neighbor,
commit to somebody else.
Because when you do that,
you're much more likely
to follow through because
you won't let them down.
You'll let yourself down all the time.
You'll let yourself down
every morning when you wake up
and hit the snooze button.
You're letting yourself down.
The first thing you do in the
morning is let yourself down.
You set a goal,
Boom. I let myself down.
You let yourself down all the time.
But you won't let other
people down nearly as much.
So take immediate action,
and then follow through
with somebody else so that
you don't let yourself,
and them down.
So the question of the day today is,
I'm curious, what is one big
goal you have, and one action
that you're going to take
today, not tomorrow, right
now, right after posting
this comment, you're going to
go take action, immediately?
Leave it down in the comments below.
Really curious to find out.
I also want to give a
quick shout out to Julia
from insidethejewelbox.com.
Julia, thank you so much for
picking up a copy of my book,
Your One Word.
I really, really, really
appreciate the support,
and I hope you're enjoying the read.
Thank you guys again for watching.
I believe in you.
I hope you continue to believe in yourelf,
and whatever your one word is.
Much love and I'll see you
guys again tomorrow morning
for another shot of Entspresso.
- ♫ I wake up every morning
♫ Entspresso keep me going
- Take action.
Whatever you want to do, whatever
you're thinking about it,
you will not get it until you
take action, make that move.
Make it a small step.
If you want a house, go get a rug.
You know what I mean?
If you want a new car, go
get some car freshener.
Take action. Make this
thing happen for you,
and it will happen.
Action, action, action.
You know one thing that
I can really attribute
to every failure in my life,
whether it be personal,
financial, any kind of
way, business, whatever,
it's because of a lack of
my attempt to take action.
I did not take action.
And, it kind of changed
once I got the fact that
action is the key.
It changed my life.
- You have to actually show up every day
and inch yourself forward
toward these dreams.
And not only show up every
day and once in a while
inch yourself, I mean every
day, you have to actually
take an action that moves you forward.
Not just research, not just thinking.
Look, the power of the intention is great,
but without any initiative
it's dead, right.
A dream is great, but without
any movement, it's dead.
You have to be moving
towards it every day.
You can send an email every
day, you can make a call
every day, you can write
something every day,
you can create something
everyday, you can contribute
something every day,
but it has to be daily.
Otherwise it will never become actualized.
The highest performers in
the world didn't get there
cause they were lucky.
They worked at it longer
than everyone else.
They had a better work
ethic, and it's not that they
necessarily always worked harder.
They worked smarter because
they were doing the research,
they were taking the time
to visualize how they
would be distinct, different,
how they would survive
the tough times.
They really kept at it.
Keep every single day
momentum going, and if
you don't do that, there's no chance.
- One of the functions of
belief is taking action.
We did a survey of about
2000 top entrepreneurs,
and we noticed that one
of the things that people
who win in that world
have is a bias for action.
If they have an
inspiration, they act on it.
How many of you have
ever had a great idea,
talked about it, thought
about it, didn't do it.
Then someone else did
it and was successful,
and you went, darn, I
should have done that?
Maybe it was buy that piece of property.
You notice we all have
that piece of property
we wish we'd bought?
You know.
Anyway, so we're going
to be looking at the idea
that taking action is
part of law of attraction.
See, a lot of people think
you just sit in your room,
meditate, visualize
having the perfect car,
the perfect house, the
perfect relationship,
then it'll kind of just come to you.
And I always say, unless you
live at the bottom of a hill,
(laughter
where there's a road, there's
probably not going to be
a Cadillac showing up in your living room,
(laughter)
right.
So, think about this, the
last six letters of the word,
attraction, spell what?
- Action.
- A-C-T-I-O-N, action.
Now there's two kinds of
actions that are critical.
There's obvious actions.
If you want a certain kind
of car, you should go down
and test drive it.
You should find out how much it costs.
You should see what it
costs to maintain it.
You should go, you know, spend,
I like to test drive a car
three or four times, go down
to the dealer, take a camera,
stick my head out the window
and say, take a picture of me,
I'll be back to buy it.
(laughter)
Put it up on my refrigerator,
look at it every day.
Eventually, you know, those kind
of things produce car, right,
saving for it and so forth.
But there are also things
called inspired actions.
All of a sudden, you get an
inspiration to do something,
and you didn't know what it was.
You don't have the sense of
like, how's this rationally
going to make sense for me
to move forward in my life?
I'll give you an example.
A friend if mine, Dr.
Ignatius Piazza, graduates
chiropractic school.
He wants to move to
Monterey, near Pebble Beach,
where the golf course is.
And he gets there and he says to the local
Chiropractic Association,
like to join you,
I'd like you to help me
get my practice started,
and they said, we don't
need any more chiropractors.
We have one chiropractor
for every eight people
in this area; there's too many.
Now he could've said, okay, let
the external reality control
his internal experience,
but he didn't do that.
He said I'm going to think
about this, and visualize it,
and believe in it, and something
will come that I will do.
And what came to him to
do was to take six months
before he opened his
office, and put a pin where
he wanted his office and
in concentric circles,
knock on every door in
every neighborhood, saying,
Hi, I'm a new doctor
in town, can I ask you
a few questions?
You know, I'm starting
this practice, should I
open from five til nine in the
morning, or should I be open
from five until nine at
night for people who have
nine to five jobs?
Which would be better?
Should I advertise in
this paper, or that paper?
Should I call it Ignatius
Piazza Chiropractic,
or Chiropractic West?
And then his last question
was, if I have an open house,
would you like to receive an invitation?
They said yes, he wrote it down.
Now over six months, he
knocked on 12,500 doors,
talked to 6,500 people, and
gathered over 4,000 names
of people who said, yes,
I'd like an invitation
to your open house.
Now, when he opened his
office six months later
in a town that did not
need another chiropractor,
according to the professionals,
his first month in practice
he netted $72,000.
(gasps)
In his first year in
practice, his gross income
was over a million dollars.
I was giving a talk and
mentioned this story
just about five years
ago, and this happened
about 25 years ago.
Someone said, he knocked on my door.
(laughter)
And he left his card.
And two years later, I
needed a chiropractor,
and I called him.
Because we work with
people we know, we've had
an experience with, right.
So he trusted his intuition,
he took action on it.
Other people would say, uh,
guess I can't have what I want.
You got to be willing to take the action.